Bueno la verdad es que el ver cómo se
reparten culpas y es desgarrador cuando
uno ve las imágenes de lo del de esas
personas varadas en la frontera más aún
cuando mayoritariamente estamos hablando
de personas venezolanas y haitianas que
provienen de países que están en graves
crisis humanitarias y de derechos
humanos y que lo que necesitan es
protección internacional no militares
diciéndoles que no pueden pasar y acá la
ausencia de una respuesta coordinada
Hasta ahora ha sido parte de lo que ha
generado el problema En definitiva
y parece que chile y Perú avanzan en la
creación de un corredor humanitario pero
ustedes denuncian que algunos migrantes
como los haitianos no pueden volver a su
país por la situación humanitaria que se
vive allí soluciona algo un corredor
humanitario o es simplemente un parche a
esta crisis
puede llegar a ser un parche va a
depender un poco también de cómo
simplemente y para qué se implemente
pero como bien dices personas
venezolanas y haitianas
pues para ellos pueden no ser una opción
el volver a sus países son países que
están en tremendas crisis humanitarias y
Derechos Humanos que no les ofrecen un
espacio seguro y ellos llegaron a Chile
a Perú o a muchos otros países en busca
de un lugar seguro donde vivir y lo que
están encontrando es discriminaciones
estigmatizaciones criminalización y
además estas respuestas individuales de
cada uno de los estados que En
definitiva van generando un efecto
dominó en que estas personas no
literalmente no tienen un lugar donde
estar y Y eso es lo lo que es
desgarrador y lo que es también un
incumplimiento por parte de las
obligaciones en materia de derechos
humanos y de derecho internacional de
los refugiados por parte de cada uno de
los países de supuesta acogida
precisamente de ese efecto dominó del
que me habla quería hablarle Yo también
porque denuncian en su comunicado dicen
que provoca como estas medidas provocan
como la militarización contrarias al
derecho internacional provocan este
efecto dominó se está viviendo un
retroceso al respecto de este derecho en
toda la región
y una crisis importante en materia de
protección internacional
Venezuela es una de los es un país que
está en crisis hace mucho tiempo y que
está generando lo que es probablemente
la peor crisis de refugiados actual en
el mundo estamos hablando de más de
siete millones de personas venezolanas
que están fuera de Venezuela tratando de
encontrar un lugar donde vivir y y no
tenemos una dimensión tan Clara de
Cuántas son las personas haitianas pero
es también una situación de extrema
crisis y en que no ha habido una
respuesta adecuada y en que muchas veces
uno escucha historias de personas
venezolanas y haitianas que han pasado
de país en país en cada uno de esos
países han vivido discriminación han
vivido violencia han vivido
criminalización tratan de irse a otro
país y vuelven a vivir la misma historia
entonces En definitiva son personas que
no para ellos volver a sus países No
necesariamente es una solución y que
tampoco encuentran un lugar seguro y que
los gobiernos no están dando una
respuesta Entonces en ese sentido sí ha
habido un agravamiento de
del problema una crisis verdad una
verdadera crisis de protección y de
falta de Liderazgo para asegurar una
respuesta coordinada que garantice los
derechos de estas personas resguardando
las obligaciones internacionales que
tienen los estados en materia de
migración y refugio y en particular en
materia de refugio y protección
internacional y Qué acciones concretas
Se podrían dar de inmediato para al
menos aliviar la situación de estas
personas
Por lo pronto tiene mucho que ver con el
asegurar primero la posibilidad de
darles un lugar digno donde puedan estar
el asegurar los recursos para procesar
la solicitudes para que los distintos
países puedan efectivamente procesar la
solicitudes por ejemplo de quienes
solicitan Refugio de solicitantes de
asilo que de hecho eso es algo que ni en
Perú ni en Chile está operando de manera
adecuada en los últimos años
por diferentes razones y Y a partir de
ahí ir priorizando los recursos para
generar esta respuesta coordinada y
poder asegurar que estas personas que
necesitan protección internacional
efectivamente la reciban y y ahí hay
medidas urgentes en que como decías
antes del corredor humanitario puede ser
una solución temporal y que permita que
estas personas no estén ahí varadas en
la frontera pero que no necesariamente
les da respuesta a la necesidad de
protección que tienen y ahí es
importante que que todos los gobiernos
de la región se te pongan en
se pongan realmente a buscar esa
respuesta coordinada